you burn the candles at both Hey look I
do a lot of stand-up and I I'm I am a
drinker and I yeah you enjoy a good time
I take drugs and whatnot yeah not not
constantly I'm also a father and what
type of stuff so I try to act
responsibility sort of responsible
Thursday's you could even say it I try
to act responsibility which means you
don't at all here's what I'm worried
about Jim and I'm concerned about it is
that this is a real article this is not
a joke this is a real article that
showed up just before your last
scheduled appearance this was a real
thing in multiple today Austrian comic
actor Jim Jefferies killed in Malta
after car crash explained how personal
the most offensive thing about that is
when I do die please find a better photo
yeah look at that I've got my original
teeth in that one that's what retinas
made a baggage carrousel but taken by
TMZ at LAX we're always talking about
Kim Kardashian getting robbed Yeah right
so yeah please no I wasn't in Malta I
didn't die in a car accident it turns
out there was a guy called Jim Jefferies
who died in the car accident and so
sorry to his family I think you just
made them feel a lot better
well they got a bit of press out of it
yeah a pleasant but anyway so so what
happened was the reporters didn't do
their due diligence and and then they
sort of someone was dead they decide it
was me now what happened was I like five
minutes after that came out someone sent
me the article and I sent out a tweet
going well I'm not dead
it's all fine I'm not dead I should have
left it just left gonna let it play out
for six hours and see if anyone would
miss me but I got in before all the
noise ah he was a great comic ID so say
that he's dead no one seemed to give a
[ __ ] no one kid my brother did send it
to my mother though my brother no she no
you can do that your mother's text or a
direct link and then they'd turn these
phone off
[Laughter]
that's terrible did you with your mom
well she's alright she's fine she's well
what am I meant to do with the woman she
yeah I think she would know that there
would be some media in Australia if I
died properly then something in bloody
Malta I've never been to multi there's
no comedy clubs in Malta I know I
haven't been there great okay so you you
just relied on her to figure it out yeah
a little bit of detective work yeah okay
good for you
you